[Applaus]
[Musik]
finnland ist es viele verrückte dinge
berühmt zum beispiel seien wohl
klingende sprache mit ihren endlos
erscheinenden aneinanderreihung von
enzymen und sage und schreibe 15 fällen
wenn man gönnt sich ja sonst nichts
daran hätten die finden noch die
weltweit höchste konzentration an heavy
metal bands prokop anzubieten und das
habe ich mir nicht ausgedacht jemand hat
im internet eine studie darüber erstellt
und sogar eine karte dazu gemalt falls
er jetzt aber der gerettet war heute
schon genug über finnland gelernt und
könnte das video abschalten überlegt
sich lieber noch mal denn heute
konzentrieren wir uns auf etwas was noch
weitaus weltbewegende ist als
komplizierte grammatik und heavy metal
den beginn einer nie dagewesenen ära in
der sicherheitsarchitektur nicht nur
europas sondern der ganzen welt deren
tragweite verursache aller sicherheit
und wohlergehen gar nicht hoch genug
eingeschätzt werden kann wir reden hier
über nichts geringeres als den anfang
vom ende der russischen atommacht im
ersten wichtigen schlüssel der globalen
nato strategie bei welcher es darum geht
den russischen atom- während seiner
gefährlichsten szene zu ziehen und die
welt aus einer nuklearen geiselhaft zu
befreien aber eins nach dem anderen
sicher habt ihr alle vor kurzem
schlagzeilen die die folgende verdienen
können schweden und finnland reich natur
werbung an offiziellen hand in hand
einer tja was für ein schlag für
russland besonders im fall finnlands
warum werdet ihr am ende dieses videos
genau verstehen wenn ihr also nichts
dagegen gehabt werden wir uns in diesem
video deswegen ein wenig mehr auf
bildern konzentrieren und ich weiß dass
ihr über diese story schon viel in den
nachrichten gehört habt in diesem video
werden wir noch ein paar sehr
interessante zusammenhänge ausgraben und
miteinander verknüpfen die bei euch
durch aus dem ein oder anderen aha
effekt auslösen und eure sicht auf die
welt von morgen ändern könnten also ran
an dopamin
[Musik]
die erste frage lautet warum ist gerade
diese entwicklung für russland ein
desaster epochalen existenziellen ausmaß
ist wie wichtig sind schweden und
finnland überhaupt die nato essen endes
geht es doch um zwei länder mit einer
relativ kleinen bevölkerungszahl
schweden hat etwas mehr als zehn
millionen einwohner und finnland sogar
nur knapp über 5,5 millionen warum ist
gerade er nato-beitritt eine tragödie
für russland auf welche probleme konnten
die beiden länder auf den weg dorthin
stoßen können sie wirklich der nato
beitreten und was könnte russland tun um
dies zu verhindern heute werden wir all
diese fragen beantworten und zwar wie so
oft in dem zuerst einen schnellen blick
in die geschichte werfen
geschichte wiederholt sich
auch wenn dies für viele leute außerhalb
wenn das erstmal merkwürdig klingt die
ukraine ist für den land ein
gigantisches déjà vu die beiden länder
haben so viele gemeinsamkeiten dass das
ganze wie ein remake der gleichen story
aussieht nur mit anderen charakteren wie
die ukraine war nämlich auch finnland
als teil des russischen reiches im jahr
1917 erlangten die vielen die
unabhängigkeit doch 1939 beschuss da
lenkt alles einfach diese wieder
einzukassieren und da er gerade dabei
war zusammen mit seinem diktatoren
kumpel hitler puls überfallen über viele
auch noch die junge demokratie der
finnen mit seiner ach so heldenhaften
und gerechten roten armee und ihr fragt
euch jetzt vielleicht welche gründe die
sowjets hatten um bei den armen szenen
einzufallen welche begründung fanta
kreml damals für den angriffskrieg gegen
finnland nun schaut euch einfach dieses
sowjetische propaganda plakat an ganz
genau es ist exakt das wonach es
aussieht ein nazi der ein kleiner hund
an der leine führt der kleine hund soll
finnland darstellen und der text besagt
der hund des verschifften welt so
sieht's aus los darling musste russland
finnland angreifen um es zu zu
entnazifizierung wie ihr also seht
stadtteil in seiner heutigen putin schon
verkörperung in sachen heuchelei
scheinheiligkeit und dreiste lüge in
nichts nach vor allem wenn man bedenkt
dass er mit nazi-deutschland gerade
einen pakt gegen polen geschlossen hatte
auf jeden fall brach so oder so genannte
winterkrieg aus ein krieg den russland
in ein paar wochen zu gewinnen durfte in
die sowjetunion war finnland an allen
fronten zahlenmäßig überlegen die rote
armee hat er mehr soldaten bessere
waffen und mehr geld doch die finnen die
leisteten erbitterten widerstand
sie kann das gelände viel besser und sie
wussten wie sie der eisigen kälte
widerstehen konnten und bis heute
unterhält finnland immer noch ganze
regimenter von soldaten auf skiern
in diesen krieg agenten kinohelden
schmiedet besser bekannt als der weiße
tod er war der tödlichste schafs oder
geschichte mit 505 bestätigen tötungen
viele davon offiziere
nach 100 tagen krieg unter den
extremsten bedingungen die man sich
vorstellen kann zog sich die rote armee
schließlich zurück aber viele von euch
kennen diese geschichte wahrscheinlich
schon was jedoch nicht erwähnt wird ist
dass finnland den krieg nicht wirklich
gewonnen hat zumindest handelt es sich
nicht um einen durchschlagenden sieg die
finnen hatten zwar ihre haut gerettet
mussten im friedensvertrag jedoch
demütigende bedingungen akzeptieren
abgesehen von den menschlichen kosten
und den kriegsschäden musste benannt
tatsächlich 300 millionen dollar als
reparationen an russland zahlen oder
eine vorstellung davon zu geben das
wären in heutigen geld etwa 5,8
milliarden dollar außerdem annektierte
russland einige regionen in nordfinnland
und einen großen fall von karelien und
die frage die sich viele von euch ist
wahrscheinlich stellen war es das wert
war es richtig dass finnland russland
die stirn geboten hat oder wäre es
vielleicht besser gewesen gleich
aufzugeben die antwort könnte nicht
deutlicher ausfallen ja es war absolut
wert zu kämpfen jeder schweiß und blut
tropft und hat sich für die finnen
tausendfach gelohnt denn die alternative
wäre einfach nur schrecklich gewesen und
das ist keine hypothetische behauptungen
die wir hier einfach so aufstellen ihr
wollt harte beweise und fakten dafür nun
die daten sprechen für sich
heute haben die finnen ein pro kopf bip
von 49.000 dollar in der damals an
russland abgetreten republik karelien
sind es weniger als 7.000 170 dollar und
die lebenserwartung und finnland liegt
sie weit 81 jahren auf der anderen seite
der grenze bei 73 soziale ungleichheit
finnland ist mit einem gini
koeffizienten von 27,7 als der egalität
ersten länder der welt die russen
hingegen stehen mit einem wert von 35,3
weit abgeschlagen auf platz 98 irgendwo
zwischen wotan gabun und burundi mit
anderen worten egal welchen indikator
wir uns ansehen finnland liegt heute auf
den obersten rängen und russland auf den
unteren zweifellos fragen sich die arme
karelien an der grenze zu finnland heute
jeden tag warum sich ihre vorfahren
ausgerechnet und der grenze zum
russischen schiphol bereich ansiedeln
mussten und tatsächlich ist die republik
karelien eine der regionen mit der
geringsten unterstützung für putins
partei das spielt in der russischen
demokratie allerdings kommen eine rolle
mit anderen worten auf der ganzen welt
gibt es nur sehr wenige ähnlich krasse
beispiele dafür was für einen großen
unterschied im leben der bürger eine
landesgrenze ausmachen kann aber die
frage die ich jetzt vielleicht alle
stellt ist warum ist es der finnland und
schweden so wichtig der nato beizutreten
was bringen sie den bündnis handelt es
sich eher um einen symbolischen schritt
oder steckt mehr dahinter nun das werden
wir uns erst mal genauer ansehen
[Musik]
die die finanzierung
finnland und schweden sind zwei der am
schwierigsten einzelnen länder der welt
sie sind zwei beispiel für das was wir
totale sicherheit nennen könnten das
heißt die gesamte gesellschaft ist auf
eine invasion vorbereitet vom militär
bis zur zivilbevölkerung
um euch eine vorstellung davon zu geben
es ist in schweden der als 65.000 kriegs
bunker in einigen schwedischen region
ist sogar pflicht dass jedes haus einen
eigenen bunker hat in helsinki in
hauptstadt finnlands geht es mehr als
5.500 punkte außerdem verfügen sowohl
finnland als auch schweden über gut
ausgerüstete armee die perfekt an die
anforderung der nato angepasst sind
aber es gibt noch etwas viel wichtigeres
als alters der große beitrag finnlands
und schwedens zur nato ist die geografie
hat nun einen blick auf diese karte
[Musik]
was ihr hier seht ist die ostsee
finnland schweden und estland
kontrollieren den gesamten russischen
weg zur ostsee von sankt petersburg aus
island ist bereits mitglied der nato und
wenn finnland beitritt könnte die nato
den verkehr aller russische schiffe die
sankt petersburg verlassen blockieren
und ihr werdet vielleicht sagen okay
aber russland hat immer noch zugang zum
baltikum und zwar über kaliningrad nicht
so schnell denn direkt vor kaliningrad
schweden das ebenfalls kurz vor dem
beitritt zur nato steht
[Musik]
und zu schweden gehört auch jede insel
hier siehst gott land der springende
punkt ist ist vor einigen monaten war
diese insel entmilitarisiert aber das
ist jetzt geschichte schweden hat
truppen nach gut land entsandt um dort
eine ständige operationsbasis zu
errichten denn von dort aus kann es das
gesamte gebiet der ostsee kontrolliert
ja putin wollte also verhindern dass die
nato an der russischen grenze steht
jetzt wird es an dem einzigen punkt an
dem es freien zugang zum atlantik hat
von der nato nur so umzingelt sein und
dies hat konsequenzen wahrlich
geopolitischen und geostrategischen
charakters wenn die russen nämlich zum
beispiel ein u boot mit der
atomsprengköpfe nirgendwo in den
atlantik schicken wollen ist es für
dieses nun unmöglich nicht entdeckt zu
werden
[Musik]
vergesst bitte nicht dass alle nato
armeen informationen austauschen um sich
jeden russischen u-boot sofort mehrere
britische und amerikanische u-boote an
die fersen heften und den ersten fall
zerstören würde noch bevor es seine
raketen abschießen kann das ist der
grund warum und fast alle russischen
atom u boote nutzlos in ihren häfen
versauern müssen aber ich weiß dass
viele von euch jetzt denken ist die
ostsee wirklich so wichtig für russland
technisch gesehen haben sie doch auch
noch zugang vom schwarzen meer aus der
das schwarze meer ist eine ziemlich
spannende gegen schott einfach mal diese
karte an
[Musik]
wenn ihr euch schaut werdet ihr sehen
dass die einzige ausfahrt aus dem
schwarzen meer zum mittelmeer die
meerengen bosporus ist die komplett
türkei kontrolliert wird und ja die
türkei ist auch ein nato-mitglied mit
anderen worten russland wird er dabei
sein die kontrolle über alle seine
zugänge zu mehr zu verlieren zumindest
im westen aber nicht nur das darf man
einen blick auf diese dritte karte
[Musik]
die landzunge die auf der russischen
seite seht ist die kola halbinsel hier
befinden sich schätzungsweise den
meisten atoms der welt denn in diesem
gebiet hat russland wahrscheinlich fast
alle seine nuklearen sprengköpfe
verbuddelt und luftstützpunkte errichtet
aber das ist noch nicht alles denn wie
so oft scheint die russische armee auch
an dieser stelle die bedeutung der
militär logistik noch unglaubliche weise
unterschätzt zu haben wir haben ist
kreisen zufolge sind nämlich all diesen
militärbasen nur durch eine einzige
eisenbahnlinie verbunden das ist kein
witz der größte teil des russischen
atomwaffenarsenals ist nur durch eine
einzige bahn linie verbunden somit
bräuchte es noch einen gut organisierten
angriff und alle logistik linien des
atomarsenals versorgung würden
zusammenbrechen bislang stellte die ist
alles kein großes problem für russland
dar denn die einzigen die in der lage
waren diese eisenbahnlinie zu
montierende anzugreifen waren die
neutralen finden an dieser stelle müssen
wir jedoch noch mal kurz an unsere
geschichtsstunde von vorhin anknüpfen
denn es ist sehr wichtig zu verstehen
was nach den winterkrieg eigentlich mit
finnland los war finnland wollte sich
der verlust karelin ist nämlich nicht
gefallen lassen und sah er seine stunde
gekommen als hitlers darlehens liebe
nicht ganz so ähnlich erwiderte wie sich
das letztere vorgestellt hatte 1941
griff es gemeinsam mit deutschen truppen
im sogenannten fortsetzungs krieg die
sowjetunion an im september 1944 wurde
jedoch ein waffenstillstand geschlossen
und 947 ein aktives vertrag
unterzeichneten wind inland weitere
gebiete an die sowjetunion abtreten
musste und ein jahr später wurde dann
der finnische sowjetischer vertrag
unterzeichnet und der hatte es in sich
finnland ordnete sich darin quasi das
publikum unter und blieb bis zum fall
des eisernen vorhangs strikt und
überkorrekt neutral wobei es deswegen
oft wegen vorauseilenden gehorsams
gegenüber sowjetunion kritisiert wurde
den rahmen dieser neutralität ließ sich
sogar erhebliche eingriffe aus moskau in
die eigene in politik gefallen so dass
man von einem zustand verminderter
selbstständigkeit sprechen kann ja sogar
von einer beschnittenen demokratie denn
die finnische regierung glaubte sie
müsste zur wahrung ihrer neutralität
gegenüber den damaligen sowjetischen
reich des bösen da die presse und
meinungsfreiheit der eigenen bürger
beschränken mit sie ja niemandem in
kreml verstimmen mit dieser buckel
politik prägte das nordische land sein
eigenes schlagwort finnland visierung
dieses wird immer dann verwendet wenn
man ausdrücken möchte das eine mächtige
nachbarstadt starken einfluss auf seinen
kleineren nachbarn und dessen politik
ausübt und junge wie finalisierung als
politische mentalität sollte auch nach
dem fall der sowjetunion in finnland
weiter nach den hessing gewandelte es
weiterhin nur so von feigen russland
apologeten so dass sich die herrscher in
kreml lange in sicherheit wiegen und
sicher sein konnten die finnen würden
sich ihm gegenüber schon nichts traut
ihre atomanlagen im finnischen
hinterland hielten sie deswegen lange
für sich habe all das hat sich jetzt
geändert und ihr könnt euch nun bestimmt
vorstellen was für eine aufregung das im
kreml ausgelöst hat nebenbei bemerkt das
bedeutet natürlich nicht dass russland
alle seine atombomben verlieren würde
aber es ist klar das ist in russland
schwieriger wäre auf sein gesamtes
atomwaffenarsenal zurückzugreifen es
handelt sich also um den ersten
wichtigen schritt auf dem weg zur
atomaren die militarisierung des
russischen terror stars der oder sein
nukleares drohpotenzial wirklich nichts
mehr auf die geopolitischen waagschale
bringen könnte es geht quasi um die
existenz eines reiches das vollständig
um sein atomwaffenarsenal herum gebaut
ist mit anderen worten mit dem beitritt
zur nato wird etwas geschehen dass sich
russland im grunde gar nicht leisten
kann der worst case wird eintreten die
frage ist also was können die russen
noch tun um all das zu verhindern nur
genau das werden wir jetzt unter die
lupe nehmen
auf die richtigen freunde kommt an
wie oft habt ihr schon vor der bösen
nato-erweiterung gehört laut der
russischen propaganda ist die nato wie
ein ölteppich der ein land nach dem
anderen verschluckt erobert die wir
allerdings in diesem fall gut sehen
können ist nicht die nato die expandiert
es sind die länder die sich von russland
bedroht fühlen und schutz suchen welche
proaktiv an die nato herantreten der
beitritt senator ist jedoch kein
automatischer prozess und vom zeitpunkt
an dem ein land seinen antrag auf
mitgliedschaft gestellt bis zum
endgültigen beitritt gibt es eine zeit
in der es besonders bedroht ist überlegt
mal sobald schweden und finnland der
nato beitreten kann russland sie nicht
mehr angreifen denn das leere angriff
auf die nato als ganzes der bündnisfall
würde eintreten doch bis es soweit ist
könnte russland kleine vielleicht
hybride angriffe starten ohne dass die
nato gewohnt wäre zu reagieren und das
erklären drohungen wie diese russland
droht mit militärisch technischen
vergeltungsmaßnahmen gegen finanz nato
bewerbung aber was könnte russland tun
[Musik]
im prinzip könnte es zum beispiel
marschflugkörper auf bestimmte
strategische standorte ins inland
beschießen sie könnten kraftwerke und
kommunikationsanlagen sabotieren oder
sogar zerstören und die gesamte
wirtschaft damit zusammenbrechen lassen
und ohne die unterstützung der nato wäre
finnland nicht in der lage zu reagieren
oder gleich auch großbritannien schließt
ein neues sicherheitsabkommen mit
schweden und finnland ab so sieht es aus
bei johnson war schneller als die nato
selbst bevor die anderen mitglieder
entscheiden ob sie finden und schweden
aufnehmen hat das vereinigte königreich
bereits eine militärische zusammenarbeit
zugesagt das heißt wenn moskau angreift
antworten und london vergesst nicht dass
großbritannien über atomwaffen verfügt
und das ist noch lange nicht alles nach
dem schritt des vereinigten königreichs
haben andere länder sofort nachgezogen
als nächstes kam polen und dann die usa
das opportunitätskosten land hat sich
also bereits geschlossen
obwohl finnland und schweden noch nicht
in der nato sind habe sie bereits die
unterstützung zweier atommächte gut dann
könnte russland doch mit
wirtschaftlichen maßnahmen angreifen
aber klar doch der kreml hat das
angekündigt dass alle gaslieferungen
nach dem land stopp was ist ein problem
aber aus militärischer sicht haben sie
immer weniger möglichkeiten und das
erklärt rau sich moskaus diskurs wenige
tage nach der androhung so viele
repressalien radikal verändert hat
russlands aussenminister sergej lavrov
sagt der beitritt finnland und schweden
zur nato mache keinen großen unterschied
ja auf einmal macht es keinen großen
unterschied mehr eine lappalie
und ich weiß was erst wenn die russland
nichts mehr tun kann ist es nur noch
eine frage der zeit bis 10 an der nato
beitritt oder kann da überhaupt noch
etwas schiefgehen schauen wir mal
[Musik]
wie auf dem basar
im prinzip verfolgt die nato eine
politik der offenen tür das heißt
finnland und schweden können ohne
probleme beitreten das problem ist
jedoch dass alle mit isländer dies
akzeptieren müssen und zwar einstimmig
und welche länder würden ein veto gegen
den weiteren schwedens und finnlands zur
nato einlegen wollen und hauptsächlich
zwei ungarn und die türkei vor allem die
türkei
der türkische präsident erdogan hat muss
die dato bewerbungen schwedens und
finnlands mit der auslieferung von
terroristen der hintergrund die türkei
kämpfen seit jahren gegen die kurdische
minderheit
sie hat mehrere kurdische organisationen
auf ihrer liste terroristischer gruppen
sowohl schweden als auch finnland haben
jedoch mitglieder dieser organisationen
politisches asyl gewährt die beiden
länder haben es abgelehnt 33 personen
auszuliefern und nach ansicht der türkei
handelt es sich um zusammenarbeit mit
terroristen erdogan ist nicht bereit den
weiteren schwedens und finnlands zur
nato zu akzeptieren solange sie mit
ihnen nicht in seinem kampf gegen die
kurden kooperieren aber wir sprechen
nicht nur von kunden laut erdogan stehen
auch die anhänger von fethullah gülen
auf der liste terroristischen gruppen
wahrscheinlich erinnert ihr euch daran
dass bülent einer von apples größten
politischen freunden ist nun von ihnen
für den putsch von 2016 verantwortlich
gemacht wird die frage ist allerdings
ist dies wirklich der einzige grund der
wahren grund nun höchstwahrscheinlich
nicht
[Applaus]
da habe es schon mehrmals auf visuelle
politik gesagt die türkei ist der bad
boy der nato und das bedeutet dass die
usa ein veto gegen den verkauf ihrer
waffen an ankara eingelegt haben die
türkei kann es zum beispiel keine f-35
kaufen allerdings kann sie jetzt ihr
vetorecht nutzen um neu zu verhandeln
erdogan macht die nato mal wieder zu
seinem war sarah und ihr werdet staunen
wie clever und hinterlässt sich die
türken dabei vorgeht die regierung von
präsident recep tayyip erdogan hat sogar
ein geheimnis plan ausgeheckt um einen
keil zwischen schweden und finnland zu
treiben der coo der von erdogan beratern
und diplomaten des türkischen
außenministeriums sorgfältig geplant
wurde verfolgt zwei ziele das erste
basierte auf privaten mitteilungen an
die delegationen der beiden länder
anzudeuten dass die türkei ist eine
gegenüber den anderen bevorzugen könnte
die türken unterbreiteten mehrere
vorschläge um den eindruck zu erwecken
dass ein land bessere chancen hat als
das andere wenn es den türkischen
forderungen nach gibt
[Musik]
der zweite teil der türkischen taktik
konzentrierte sich darauf die
öffentliche debatte zu beeinflussen
damit unterschwelligen andeutungen über
die angeblichen unterschiede zwischen
den beiden ländern und die art und weise
wie die türkei jeden antrag separat
behandeln möchte in seinen öffentlichen
äußerungen konzentrierte sich präsident
erdogan in seinen angriffen vor allem
auf schweden und nicht auffinden der in
erdogans anhänger kasten das nordische
land für alles was es repräsentiert
seine tradition der wahrung von
bürgerrechten und freiheiten
konfliktvermeidung konsensbildung das
streben nach einer regelbasierten
weltordnung und das was schweden als
feministische außenpolitik bezeichnet
neben rüstung geht es erdogan also auch
ob innenpolitik und die bevorstehenden
wahlen in der türkei er will die
beitritts anträge schwedens und
finnlands noch schnell bis september
ausnutzen um seine islamistische kern
basis aufzuhetzen und seine
nationalistische und neo
nationalistischen verbündeten zu spielen
doch erdogan möchte das thema auch dazu
nutzen um mit der us-regierung über die
einstellung eines bestimmten
gerichtsverfahrens in new york zu
verhandeln dass ihnen wegen illegaler
geschäfte der staatlichen türkischen
kreditbank halkbank mit iranischen
unternehmen persönlich strafrechtlich
belasten würde ihr seht also für erdogan
ist hier viel im spiel was rein gar
nichts mit der nato finden dann schweden
und russland zu tun hat und er wird sein
blatt bis zu anschlag ausreizen tja und
siehe da erscheint genau das zu bekommen
was er möchte
die türkei bestätigt dass großbritannien
das embargo für rüstungsexporte
aufgehoben hat die nato wird also wieder
waffen an die türkei verkaufen als ob
nichts geschehen wäre und wird im
gegenzug die türkei schweden und
finnland akzeptieren nun so einfach ist
das nicht wie 3 bleibt das sorgenkind
der nato unter anderem natürlich wegen
ihrer ewigen feindseligkeit gegenüber
anderen nato mitglied griechenland und
es ist sehr wahrscheinlich dass
griechenland nicht sehr glücklich
darüber sein wird wenn sein hauptgegner
wieder zugang zu den hochmodernen
us-veteran auto kommt gut aber inwieweit
könnte das andere enfant terrible ungarn
ein veto gegen diese neue
nato-erweiterung einlegen wird es
möglich sein alle diese differenzen
beizulegen
[Musik]
nun alles ist klar außer der türkei und
ungarn scheint alle anderen mitglieder
bereit zu sein die neun mitglieder
aufzunehmen die frage ist daher
eigentlich nur wie weit wollen sie gehen
um ungarn und die türkei zu überzeugen
und wie weit wird russland gehen um dies
zu verhindern wird moskau eine massive
propaganda kampagne starten um die
europäer davon zu überzeugen dass
finnland und schweden von nazis der
hersteller länder sind und wie könnten
die nächsten schritte zur atomaren
entwaffnung der russen aussehen alles
fragen die wir in zukunft sicher angehen
werden über die aber schon heute in den
kommentaren diskutieren könnt ich hoffe
dass euch dieses video gefallen hat und
ihr vielleicht auch etwas dabei gelernt
habt falls ja gibt es mit einem like das
mit und freunden und vergesst nicht dass
awo mit glöckchen und keines unserer
videos mehr zu verpassen natürlich
freuen wir uns auch jederzeit über eine
spende von euch mit dem bus hält dieses
projekt weiterzuführen in paper link
dazu findet ihr in der beschreibung
unter dem video was gut und bis bald
[Musik]